okay let's see what else is going on on
the phones at six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty let's try I don't
know if this is three one six area code
or country code 31 three one six or
country code 31 are you there hello my
name is Kenny I am calling from the
Netherlands the country soon to be
bombed by John Bolton's
special forces and see America thank you
I really like your show i watch it on a
daily basis I have a question in a
comment or an invitation sure do
Americans at any level at reciate just
how stupid an impression Trump made when
he went down that gold escalator I think
from day one people here were saying the
I see now the guy is not okay mentally
and it went on and on and on that we
entered service county here in Europe so
it was already pretty very big bigger
name dignity but now we had two years
and nothing happened you didn't we were
not able to get rid of this imbecile can
you just try to quantify how much damage
this horrible man has inflicted on the
world and the world you know it's tough
to quantify I mean it's very difficult
to when we try to quantify but it's like
every days five new things I think
that's part of the problem that this
type of erratic destruction of norms and
policy and relationships has become
normalized in such a way that it becomes
difficult emotionally and logistically
to quantify it and I think it's a real
problem but do you understand how people
in other countries look at this this is
ridiculous I do I'm in Europe right now
I'm in Paris France right now and I've
been in Europe for the last several
weeks and I understand acutely and you
know the problem is and here's really
what I think a lot of people in Europe
don't get the people that support Trump
don't care what you think they hear you
oh you're from the Netherlands I don't
care what you think you're part of the
problem your
the [ __ ] European guy so that this is a
problem that we're dealing with they
fundamentally dude they're emboldened by
the fact that the rest of the world is
horrified